The current problem with our list is
that it only shows English words.
But we want Miwok translations
to appear as well.
So here I am in the numbers activity,
and so
far we've been using a layout that is
provided by the Android framework.
And it's defined in
the simple_list_item_1.xml file.
So remember that simple_list_item_1 is
one of many types of layouts that's
been created by the Android team.
And is part of the Android framework, so
to see a list of all the layouts
in the Android framework,
check out the R.layout page in
the Android developer's guide.
So if we scroll down a bit,
we'll see the item layout
that we're interested in.
So to learn more about this layout,
I'm actually going to do
a Google search on it.
So this is the code developed
by the Android team
to develop this specific layout.
And as you can see here,
it only contains one TextView.
Now we really need a list item
that has more than one TextView.
So let's build our own
layout with two TextViews.
Then we need to assign view ids to
the TextViews as well because we'll
need to refer to these views
later in the Java code.
So at this point,
we're not too worried about the details
of the list item layout looks like.
We're just trying to get the right data
on the screen to make sure the logic in
our code is working correctly.
Then later on, we can make the list
items visually look nicer.
Now remember that the adapter knows
how to populate this list item for
a single word in the list.
And that's why we only
need the layout for
a single item because that same
pattern will be used repeatedly.
So for this exercise, I'd like you
to create a new layout file for
how a single list item should look.
And here's an example of that.
Note the 16dp pattern on both
the top and left hand side.
Also notice that the Miwok word
is on top of the English word
because we want users to pay more
attention to the Miwok word.
Later in the visual polish
section of Lesson Three,
we'll make the Miwok word even more
prominent by bolding the word.
Next, assign view IDs
to the TextViews so
that we can refer to them
later in the Java code.
And after you're done with this,
I'd like you to answer this question.
Which ViewGroup did you use as
the root view in this layout?